c'est une voix sinueuse ou alterne
moderne au logement collectif et
traditionnel case individuelle la rue
Pierre Benoît Dumas se trouve à
Saint-Benoît au bord de la rivière Dumas
Benoît Dumas cela fait pas mal de
coïncidence vous ne trouvez pas
avec qui était Pierre Benoit Dumas
de l'histoire de la réunion
sur l'histoire de Saint-Benoît
qui c'était
le commandant Pierre Benoit Dumas arrive
à Bourbon en 1727
la culture du café est en plein
développement dans l'Est
le premier directeur général du commerce
rêve déjà d'une production dépassant la
consommation du royaume il a une
ambition pour l'île le café
alors il s'attache à augmenter le nombre
d'esclaves pas des Malgaches qu'il juge
trop paresseux des Indiens
Benoît Dumas en ramène 200 de Pondichéry
il en fait aussi venir d'Afrique ce
commerce rapporte énormément à la
compagnie
deux ans plus tard il est promu
gouverneur il ne le restera que cinq ans
mais avec un coup d'éclat mettre Olivier
Levasseur dilabuse au bout d'une corde
le gouverneur d'humain doit aussi
poursuivre le découpage administratif
engagé par son prédécesseur a commencé
par saint Benoît en 1730 reconnaissante
la commune lui donne son nom et prend
sous sa coupe le quartier de Saint-André
qui deviendra commune à son tour en 1741
la même année dans le sud Benoît Dumas
autorise le père carré à construire une
église pour le quartier Saint-Étienne un
pas vers la constitution de la commune
de Saint Louis il ne sera toutefois
franchi qu'en 1815